[Musique]
aujourd'hui nous sommes à hec
le financement et des chose de très
important
c'est important pour l'animation de
l'innovation et des jeunes entreprises
innovantes du territoire paris saclay
c'est une marque qui se destinent être
une marque très important devant de
l'innovation même au niveau mondial et
le fait d'organiser la deux reprises
dans l'année
cet événement fait tilman permet
d'accompagner déjà détecté les startups
qu'il ya de nombreuses créations
d'entreprises innovantes sur le
territoire cet événement permet de
détecter et de les aider à trouver leur
financement chiffres inc c'est une borne
qui vous permet d'imprimer
instantanément et sur place ou les jeux
de vacances vos propres cartes postales
à partir de vos photos de smartphones en
voilà le principe c'est de restituer en
fait tous les toulousains de layoule de
la carte postale classique qui est un
acte spontané le plaisir de l'écriture
est un objet qui voyage mais en ajoutant
une valeur supplémentaire qui est la
personnalisation de la carte est de
faire de la carte un véritable support
de sa vision du voyage
aujourd'hui c'est une immense et auprès
d'unités pour nous de présenter notre
projet à plusieurs investisseurs
et puis on a donc un stand où on peut
les rencontrer après notre présentation
on est exactement dans la phase on a
besoin d'être accompagnés financièrement
et de tester notre projet auprès de gens
qui ont investir les investisseurs qu'on
recherche c'est des business angels vont
être capables de nous accompagner
financièrement mais aussi de nous
accompagner avec leur expertise leurs
compétences et puis leur réseau on
attend aussi beaucoup là dessus nous
notre tour c'est qu'il ya vraiment une
grande activité autour des start up on
me semble depuis quelques années que
tout le monde souhaite que des start-up
émergent en france ces stars tablas qui
ont créé l'avenir et du coup on a plein
d'opportunités de se mettre en avant
alors aujourd'hui un événement comme ça
c'est un exemple mais on a plein
d'autres événements notamment dans les
yvelines pour présenter notre projet
donc cette dynamique
à force de travail on est capable de
trouver de séduire les mains
d'investisseurs
et